vous on a entendu un petit peu cette
nostalgie peut-être une forme d'amertume
vous l'avez dit d'emblée
vous avez souffert en équipe de France
Samir Nasri vous en voulez toujours à
Deschamps Didier Deschamps
[Musique]
un petit peu ouais un petit peu parce
que je pense que
les choses auraient
pu être différentes
on aurait pu être faite de manière
différente ça c'est une certitude après
je vois que pour certains joueurs
il y a eu
ne serait pas dépasses droites mais on
oublie plus vite on oublie beaucoup plus
vite moi quand je suis revenu en équipe
de France
sous DJ Deschamps justement j'étais
vraiment épié toutes mes actions tout ce
que je tout ce que je faisais
et on ne m'a pas laissé de on m'a pas
laissé de Seconde Chance et ce qui
m'énerve le plus c'est où je suis amer
c'est qu'en 2014 je sors d'une saison
fantastique avec City où je suis où je
remporte le deuxième titre où je gagne
aussi
la carlinkup et sur le plan sportif je
méritais de ma place au Brésil en plus
c'était Brésil c'est la Coupe du monde
au Brésil c'est le pays du foot et le
fait de pas de pas l'avoir vécu
forcément
je suis amer mais c'est pas simplement
ça c'est tout ce qui est qui a débouché
après ça la plainte contre ma compagne à
l'époque tout ça donc non j'ai des
croisés il y a pas très longtemps sur
Dubaï au restaurant on sait pas dit
bonjour mais voilà
la vie continue